ach Gott Genie tut mir leid an anderen
Handschuh naja ich bin kleiner Zauber
Wasser
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu Murat 5 Minuten
eine neue Folge aus unserer Serie Kochen
und Backen auch geringen Bildungsniveau
und dazu habe ich ein ganz ganz tollen
Gast bei mir und zwar der
Bundesgrenzschutz kennt ihn das
Finanzamt in Bruchsal und die
Zahnärztekammer in Reutlingen hier haben
wir euren neuen Gast fini genau schön
dass du da bist
was ganz ganz besonderes und zwar machen
wir den neuesten Hype momentan und zwar
das nennt sich Korean Barbecue chicken
genau und Barbie chicken ist eine eine
Kette die überall momentan auf der
ganzen Welt Filialen aufmachen es ist
ein richtiger Hype und diese Filiale
gibt es inzwischen auch in Q6 Q7 in
Mannheim das heißt in diesem
Einkaufszentrum wo wir unsere haben hat
diese Filiale aufgemacht da ist richtig
viel los was ganz ganz besonderes und
deswegen machen wir Korean chicken hast
du schon mal gegessen aber ganz ehrlich
[Gelächter]
sind schon wieder unser traumtam
und hierfür haben wir euch einen ganz
tolles Rezept vorbereitet nämlich ich
muss ehrlich sein weil ich kann nicht
lügen Günni sage ich immer wieder sein
ganzes Leben ist auch Lügen aufgebaut
und jetzt kommt ein Rezept das ist vom
von unserem Kumpel Dennis dennis ist ein
Arbeitskollege von uns hier der Arbeit
mit uns ähm der hat in seinem Leben
schon zwei Sterne gekocht ist also ein
sternekocht und hat auch schon zwei
genau Zahnstein und der dennis ist
vorbereitet und ich denke mal diesen
Drogen und diese Ehre und Dennis geben
das Ding ist immer
und dann ist immer so dann sagt er
wahrscheinlich der Dennis könnt ihr auch
kochen dann würde dir sagen kann das
deswegen macht es Rezepte Dennis und wir
kochen wenn wir zwei ist kochen können
dann kannst jeder da können es auch zwei
Schimpansen machen deswegen denn es
kommt das Rezept und von uns natürlich
nach die Technik und dazu begrüßen wir
mal unseren Dennis also Applaus für
unseren Dennis
so genau Dennis erzähl uns mal was hast
du was hast was für ein Rezept ist es
was ist hier die Besonderheit an dieser
Rezept
schon gesagt ihr liebt ja auch ein
bisschen dreckig und schmutzig ne ja ja
ja
also jemand zu schicken Trump das äh die
Hähnchen Oberkeule die wird mariniert
und dann frittiert im Westen zweimal das
schon schlotzig und knusprig ist und
danach kommt noch in so eine richtig
geile Soße damit hier schön mit den
Händen reingetippt ja aber danach
ausrichten lassen muss wegen ihm
verstehen ja genau wir machen das Rezept
so dass wir es essen können und du tust
da so anrichten dass wenn tolles Foto
haben genau alles klar dankeschön
mit mit den Zutaten für die Marinade so
jetzt ähm nehmen wir unsere Zutaten für
die Marinade die können uns alle hier
reinschütten bisschen rumrühren und dann
können wir die Chicken drums
marinieren so mal alles rein die
Sojasauce und hier ist ganz ganz wichtig
ich mag keine Rezepte wo ich die Zutaten
nicht schreiben kann und wo man nicht zu
Hause haben hier haben wir zum Beispiel
Sojasauce hat normalerweise wieder zu
Hause
dann haben wir hier Reisessig das hat
auch nicht jeder zu Hause das hast du
das Reißen hast du nicht wenn ihr kein
Reisessig habt dann nimm dir ganz normal
normalen Essig auch leicht mit Wasser
verdünnen weil Reisessig ist ein
bisschen milder als unsere normaler
Essig so und deswegen ist es wirklich so
ich finde ich finde mit Zutaten zu
kochen wo die Menschen nicht finden oder
nicht zu Hause haben mich total
erschaffen und ich finde halt immer man
muss immer nach dir gehen das was der
Günni zu Hause hat haben 100% der
deutschen auch zu Hause und das was der
Günni nicht zu Hause hat das braucht man
auch nicht richtig genau so einfach
geht's zum Backpulver rein
ja genau
ein bisschen Knoblauchpulver beim
Knoblauchpulver ist so das müsste zu
Hause haben aber ich würde es euch
allgemein immer empfehlen
Knoblauchpulver und und Zwiebelpulver zu
Hause zu haben sieht ein bisschen Kaffee
mäßig aus so und jetzt ist ganz wichtig
jetzt mit den Händen richtig marinieren
das heißt diese diese hähnchenoberkeule
ist zu nehmen und richtig einzumassieren
und dafür würde ich euch wirklich auch
Handschuhe empfehlen das heißt das mache
ich kurz kündigen ja richtig mit
Handschuhen weil gratis Backpulver das
ist jetzt direkt mit der Flüssigkeit auf
der Haut vielleicht nicht gerade das
beste
eingerieben und deswegen seht ihr auch
ein bisschen so
die Handschuhe anziehen immer davor rein
Blasen da können wir reinkommen
tut mir leid ein anderen Handschuhe
diese oberkeulen
ich finde so schwarze hinten
professioneller aus gell finde ich also
und jetzt tun wir sie richtig schön
einmassieren
richtig schön einmassieren
so und das Backpulver ist wirklich da
das machen sie eine asiatischen Küche
wenn ich oft gerne weil es vielleicht
schon so richtig schön zart und saftig
bleiben
es stimmt eigentlich ja eigentlich bin
ich Asiate
jetzt könnt ihr folgendes machen das
Fleisch müsste jetzt eine halbe Stunde
mariniert lassen was ja auch machen
könnt ist aber auch kein Problem ihr
könnt es auch über Nacht einlegen
wirklich jetzt haben wir natürlich schon
wenn wir Profis sind schon was
vorbereitet wir haben das jetzt sogar
über Nacht eingelegt weil wir wussten
dass sie am nächsten Tag dass sie machen
müssen haben uns über Nacht eingelegt
und jetzt machen wir die Panade und die
Zutaten für die Panade die kannst ja
jetzt mal du vorstellen weil das die
Menschen nicht denken dass du gar nichts
machst für die Panade brauchen wir 150 g
Mehl 100 g Stärke 10 Gramm Salz und ein
Viertel Teelöffel Knoblauchpulver ja
jetzt haben die Zutaten jetzt haben wir
die Panade jetzt können wir alles hier
in die Schüssel reingeben und dann
mischen genau
macht ich mache rein
so einmal rein genau das ist die Stärke
dann haben wir hier Salz
und hier was ist dies
genau
schön richtig zu einer homogenen Masse
zusammenrühren weil sie sich ganz
wichtig weil wenn diese Panade über
diese Wings drüber geht dann ist es dann
für den Geschmack in diese Kopfnote wenn
es dann so runter geht weil ich in
diesem Abgang und und
einfach zusammen
und dann tun wir die
mal
gelesenbuch oder so aber egal hört sich
richtig clever an
richtig schön gemischt wenn man dich
halt kennt ja
ich weiß so okay jetzt werden wir
natürlich die panieren und dann werden
wir sie frittieren und zwar in
Sonnenblumenöl und es ist wirklich
leider Gottes
richtig es ist zwar nicht gesund weil
weil ihr seht was passieren kann über
viel frittiertes ist hier man Beispiel
und will nicht alles so viel ändern dann
macht er danach wieder Sport es ist ganz
wichtig und jetzt tun wir das panieren
das zeige ich kurz machen
so jetzt tun wir das mal schön rein
machen können
so und jetzt ist aber ganz wichtig
Fehler nicht machen ich mach's doch mit
den Händen genießen lieber der dennis
hat mich sonst dreckig und schmutzig
machen
so und jetzt ganz wichtig abklopfen die
Hähnchen Teile wirklich
siehst du das und jetzt ist es Fett heiß
genug
steckt mal ganz kurz den Finger rein
wenn die Finger reinstecken es gibt
Blasen dann an der Haut an der Haut
probier mal genau und zwar wenn ihr
wissen möchtet wie es ist das ob das
Fett heiß genug ist dann müsst ihr
wirklich ein Holzstab reinhängen hast du
einen Holzstab damit
und hier in dieser gusseisenwanne hier
haben wir Sonnenblumenöl drin hier haben
wir ab 180 Grad davor ist wirklich nur
anbraten oder zum gefallen die guckt
erstmal ein holzstieß tut den Holzspieß
rein und wenn dann Blasen entstehen
wisst dass es heiß genug 180 Grad
braucht ihr jetzt habe ich hier diese
Hähnchen Oberkeule und die lege ich
jetzt hier einfach rein
so
und jetzt einfach nur reinlegen
so jetzt haben wir es frittieren und es
ist ganz ganz wichtig mach jetzt Erfolge
Fehler nicht mittlich etwas länger
Frittieren aus dem Grund weil es ist
ziemlich viel Fleisch dran und ich
glaube es kann es gibt nichts
schlimmeres für mich als als Hühnchen
wenn es nicht durch ist das ist ganz
ganz schlimm beim Ring geht noch man
kann mit sogar roh essen beim
Rindfleisch aber bei Hühnchen wirklich
das muss nämlich zweimal Frittieren das
heißt wir lassen es jetzt kurz drin
frittierendes und noch mal raus und dann
Frittieren muss noch mal einen schönen
knusprig wird wichtig ist hier wirklich
dass es schön durch ist okay
und ich mache währenddessen die ganze
Soße und zwar die Soße die nachher über
diese Hähnchen Teile drüber gelegt und
das ist ganz wichtig weil das ist ja
diese Hype diese frittierten hinten
Teile mit dieser mit dieser Soße mit
dieser Marinade drüber und dazu zeige
ich euch jetzt mal die Zutaten für die
Soße braucht ihr 60 ml Sojasoße 2
Esslöffel Sesamöl zwei Esslöffel
Reisessig zwei Esslöffel Honig ein Teel
20 Gramm brauner Zucker 30 Gramm Chili
Paste zwei gepresste Knoblauchzehen
2 Esslöffel gehackten Ingwer und eine
halbe Zitrone
ja auf jeden Fall dann ist es kein Thema
wenn ihr kein Reisessig habt dann nimmt
den normalen Essig alles alles easy ja
nachts echt nach Geschmack nach dem
Freestyle was ihr zu Hause habt und das
tut mir jetzt alles einfach in den Topf
rein tust mir dann vermengen und dann du
musst aufkochen weil dann haben wir noch
mal ein besonderes Aroma aufkochen als
nicht anbrennen ganz wichtig wirklich
schön aufkochen und dann haben wir die
coole so sieht man nicht haben möchte
okay also Thomas rein was war das
Sojasoße zack
natürlich
Sesamöl
genau
wenn ich kein Sesamöl habe dann könnt
ihr zum Beispiel auch ein Erdnussöl
nehmen oder ein Walnussöl ja nein
[Musik]
du willst mich schon in die Party nein
und jetzt noch die Zitrone
[Musik]
natürlich die ganze Zitrone so jetzt
räumen wir alles auf
und während der Günni aufräumen tue ich
die Soße jetzt ganz leicht ankochen also
wirklich nur ankochen lassen genau hier
auf Stufe 4
oh die sieht richtig lecker aus die Soße
ist mir jetzt noch ein bisschen zu
flüssig also ist echt zu flüssig ich
möchte dass sie ein bisschen dicker wird
jetzt machen wir folgendes jetzt mal ein
bisschen Stärke und zwar du kennst du ne
ne ne
schwitze und zwar ein bisschen also die
Soße müssen anzudicken okay das ist
eigentlich ganz ganz easy wir nehmen ein
bisschen Wasser rein
jetzt nur ein bisschen stärker ein
bisschen Stärke rein so
jetzt Thomas bisschen und hier ist es
ganz wichtig genau richtig gemacht
kaltes Wasser zu nehmen ja kein warmes
Wasser kaltes Wasser dass sich keine
Klümpchen bilden am Rhein kippen genau
rühren rühren rühren
noch der Rest rein genau
ist die Soße schön dick okay jetzt
nehmen wir die frittierten Hähnchen
alles noch warm ganz ganz wichtig
wirklich schmeckt wirklich warm muss es
sein so können wir die rein
nicht zu viel drei Stück immer mal und
jetzt machen wir die Soße bisschen rüber
nicht alles genau nun teil
und jetzt kommt die Sauerei wieder
gesagt hat und zwar müssen wir die jetzt
Dinger einfach nur drehen
dann sagt er hat eine größere Schüssel
nehmen soll aber egal
und besser aus so mein Gott so egal es
passiert
ja es geht ja sieht zwar ein bisschen
unprofessionell aus und hier kleben da
und ich glaube der Dicke kleben so okay
jetzt müssen wir es cool machen okay
so würdest du Dennis machen denke ich so
wie wir das machen
so wie das so
ich glaube die Schüssel ist auch zu
klein
das reicht schon jetzt nehmen wir das
was geschrieben hat koriander ist so ein
echt so ein cooler Typ ich lieb das
Koriander
zu tun ob man Koriander mag oder nicht
deswegen Liebst du mich auch genau und
jetzt ist folgendes natürlich in
asiatischen Küche ganz ganz oft Sesam
zum Beispiel auch in der türkischen
Küche auch ganz oft Sesam jetzt nämlich
hier drüber weil das machen
lassen weil es muss ein Foto geschossen
werden
[Gelächter]
ganz kurz beispielsweise
überrascht
was passiert mitbekommen
ganz wichtig hier so schön oben drüber
ganz wichtig
kann man den geröstet
das schmeckt noch cooler ja
[Musik]
noch Frühlingszwiebel drauf gemacht und
Koriander
ich habe es doch gesagt
hast du in deinem Leben schon mal
Koriander gegessen
das ist sowas tolles zum Fleisch
wirklich du musst es echt mal essen
Hammer
er hat diese Gene nicht wirklich das
gibt's wirklich
bewiesen dass wenn du jetzt gemacht hast
wahrscheinlich gell
weil daran merkt man nämlich dass man
dass du dumm bist ja genau
[Gelächter]
gegessen
und ähm Abendbrot Schlechtwetter tot
okay
[Musik]
ja jetzt haben wir es fertig unser
Korean Barbecue chicken und jetzt holen
Dennis und er darf mal probieren okay
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe ein
bisschen Angst wenn ich habe nur diese
Angst ist es durch ist noch nicht durch
die einzige Chance aber es ist schon
richtig knusprig aus
[Musik]
Hammer
wow ohne Witze das war auch voll easy
also ich echt einfach
schon gegessen
ich bin mir so ein Tyrannosaurus aber
war echt lecker
auf jeden Fall macht es zu Hause nach
bitte tut uns gefallen der abonniert
diesen Kanal nicht sondern abonniert ihn
wir verlieren jedes Mal wenn günen ich
was kochen verliere mir Abonnenten
deswegen durfte mir lange Zeit nichts
machen es tut einfach gefallen
sondern abonniert diesen Kanal hättet
nicht uns hätte die anderen und wenn ihr
euch für den Dennis auch interessiert
einen eigenen Podcast wie heißt das
nochmal Mutter Mutter Natur ja
genau genau
ähm genau heute
wir haben bald eine TV Sendung ganz
wichtig ja Feierabend wir haben bei den
TV rechtlichen das heißt in Zukunft
nicht nur ich den Günni bezahlen sondern
wir alle zusammen ganz tolle Geschichte
und schaltet auch bald ein äh bald
gibt's Neues mehr dazu okay tschüss
[Musik]